bienvenidos a cachemira el lugar donde
aislarte del mundanal ruido
valles sobrecogedores
naturaleza cultura y bombas
atentados terroristas bombardeos y
violencia sistemática cachemira es el
último lugar del planeta tierra donde
querrías estar
[Música]
y en los últimos meses esta región
situada entre la india y pakistán ha
vuelto a dar de qué hablar podría ser el
inicio de una nueva guerra nuclear o tal
vez no
[Música]
en este vídeo te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sólo hay tres eventos deportivos capaces
de reunir ante las pantallas a más de
mil millones de personas en todo el
mundo una es la ceremonia de apertura de
unos juegos olímpicos otro es la final
del mundial de fútbol y el tercero es un
india pakistán de crío
[Aplausos]
habéis oído bien el cricket es el
deporte nacional entre india y pakistán
dos de los países más poblados del mundo
y dos países que se odian entre ellos y
creedme la rivalidad entre estas dos
naciones va mucho más allá del deporte
casimira sufre el peor ataque en 30 años
y no hablamos de una rivalidad menor
tanto india como pakistán son potencias
nucleares y la manzana de la discordia
es una región que se llama cachemira
ambos países se disputan el control de
esta zona
en febrero de 2019 un grupo terrorista
conectado con el ejército de pakistán
jaish-e-mohammed organizó uno de los
peores atentados terroristas en
cachemira y la india respondió con el
primer ataque de la historia en pleno
territorio pakistaní la situación no
podía ser más tensa podríamos estar ante
el inicio de una guerra nuclear pero
porque india y pakistán se llevan tan
mal y que son exactamente las doctrinas
nucleares hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas y lo vamos a hacer de la mano
de mi amigo sanders snyder que es
analista político en reconsiderar media
y un gran amigo de este canal
hola fonseca y un abrazo a todos los
suscriptores de visual político es como
dices continuamos en una situación de
duelo mexicano entre pakistán india
pero puede llegar a desembocar en una
guerra nuclear lo veo difícil pues bien
hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
'furia de titanes' tras la segunda
guerra mundial todos los territorios de
las indias se independizaron del imperio
británico hasta aquí todo muy bien pero
había un problema por estas tierras
había dos grandes grupos religiosos por
un lado teníamos a millones de
musulmanes y por el otro a millones de
hinduistas así que que hizo reino unido
[Música]
fue muy sencillo las zonas de mayoría
musulmana pasaron a formar parte de lo
que hoy conocemos como pakistán y
bangladesh y las zonas de mayoría
hinduista pasaron a ser lo que hoy
conocemos como la india pero seguía
habiendo un problema todavía quedaban
zonas grises zonas con población de
ambas confesiones pues bien cachemira
era una de estas regiones en este caso
los ciudadanos cachemires eran
principalmente musulmanes pero su
gobernante el marajá era hindú así que
dijeron ni pakistán ni india cachemira
independiente y todos contentos verdad
[Música]
pues no para nada estaban contentos dos
meses después de la proclamación de
independencia pakistán invadió cachemira
así que el marajá pidió ayuda a la india
para frenar la invasión
[Música]
es como pakistán india que eran dos
estados recién creados se enzarzaron en
su primera guerra el resultado además de
miles de muertos y millones de
desplazados es que en el año 1949
cachemira se dividió en dos partes una
para pakistán y otra para la india pero
si pensabais que bastaba con una
frontera para tener contentos a todos
estabais muy equivocados estos sus
países han llegado a tener tres guerras
por el control de cachemira las guerras
entre india y pakistán siempre han sido
iguales -las empieza a pakistán y las
gana la india a fin de cuentas son mucho
más grandes y tienen más dinero
[Música]
por estos momentos y estamos en los años
60 en aquel entonces la primera ministra
de la india era esta mujer que veis en
pantalla que se llamaba indira gandhi
y hay dos cosas que debéis saber de esta
mujer no tenía nada que ver con mahatma
gandhi y tampoco tenía nada que ver con
la paz más bien todo lo contrario para
que os hagáis una idea esta es la mujer
que decretó la vasectomía forzosa para 6
millones de hombres pobres así por las
buenas así que un buen día la señora
gandhi viendo que los paquistaníes no
dejaban de tocarla aspectos dijo a tomar
por bomba atómica en el año 1967 india
comenzó su programa atómico desde
entonces el ejército de pakistán no se
ha atrevido a volver a atacar a toda una
potencia nuclear en su lugar los
habitantes de cachemira han sufrido
continuos ataques terroristas por parte
de grupos paquistaní
[Música]
y si los terroristas no son suficientes
el gobierno de la india tampoco se anda
con paños calientes para que os hagáis
una idea desde 1990 cachemira está bajo
leyes militares o sea que la represión
es continua pero si pensabais que la
situación no podía ser más complicada
mis queridos amigos de visual política
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados en
el año 1998 las cosas cambiaron a peor
duelo mexicano enfrentarse a un país
nuclear es como salir a jugar al cricket
sin bates por eso aunque pakistán sea
mucho más pobre que la india zulfikar
alí bhutto quien entonces era el
presidente de pakistán lo tuvo muy pero
que muy claro
comeremos hierba u hojas e incluso
pasaremos hambre pero conseguiremos una
y así es como en el año 1998 pakistán
realizó sus primeras pruebas nucleares
aquí están ha sido obligada a ejercer la
opción nuclear debido al reconocimiento
del programa nuclear de la india /
program
esto ha llevado al colapso de la
disuasión existencial y ha alterado
radicalmente el equilibrio estratégico
en nuestra región
y así es como llegamos a la situación de
duelo mexicano un duelo mexicano es un
enfrentamiento en el que los oponentes
están en igualdad de condiciones de este
modo ambos están sin actuar esperando
que un elemento externo influya y la
balanza se decante hacia un lado u otro
para empezar a actuar ahora bien aunque
india y pakistán tengan bombas atómicas
hay una diferencia muy grande entre
ambos países las doctrinas nucleares la
india tiene una doctrina de no primer
uso esto significa que sólo está
dispuesta a utilizar su arsenal nuclear
si es atacada previamente con armas
nucleares
pakistán tiene una doctrina
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ellos están dispuestos a usar su arsenal
nuclear si son invadidos es decir que
aunque india no les lance bombas
atómicas
pakistán si podría usarlas en esta
doctrina juegan un papel fundamental las
llamadas armas tácticas dentro de las
armas nucleares podemos hablar de dos
tipos las más potentes son las
estratégicas que pueden destruir grandes
ciudades y se pueden mandar a miles de
kilómetros de distancia más otras son
las armas tácticas diseñadas para ser
utilizadas en un campo de batalla pues
bien el pasado enero pakistán probó sus
misiles nsr lo que provocó titulares
como ese
[Música]
pakistán equipa a los militares con
misiles tácticos con capacidad nuclear
[Música]
en otras palabras pakistán compensa su
menor poderío militar con una doctrina
nuclear más agresiva podrían utilizar
las armas tácticas contra cualquier
movimiento invasor y luego podrían
utilizar las armas estratégicas contra
los silos nucleares indios y ya sé lo
que estáis pensando
menuda doctrina nuclear más
irresponsable verdad pues espera porque
todavía no habéis visto nada el botón
nuclear de pakistán no está en manos del
gobierno sino del ejército y resulta que
en pakistán el gobierno va por un lado y
el ejército en los servicios de
inteligencia van por el otro eso explica
que los terroristas campen a sus anchas
por pakistán
muchas veces apoyados por sus propias
fuerzas armadas y todo esto también
explicaría esa relación de amor/odio
entre pakistán y eeuu
el ejército de eeuu cancela 300 millones
de dólares en ayuda a pakistán a causa
de los grupos terroristas y lo cierto es
que hay razones de sobra para desconfiar
del ejército de pakistán o se acordáis
de osama bin-laden recordáis donde lo
encontraron exacto en pakistán pero más
concretamente al lado de la academia
militar de kakul que es algo así como el
west point paquistaní
[Aplausos]
y qué tipo de grupos terroristas están
conectados al ejército pues básicamente
lo mejor de cada casa tenemos por un
lado a los yihadistas que apoyan a los
talibanes en afganistán pero hay otros
grupos como jassim mohammed quien luchan
por el control de cachemira así que da
igual si el gobierno de islamabad y el
de nueva delhi intentan llevarse más o
menos bien porque el ejército pakistaní
y los terroristas se van a encargar de
torpedear todas las posibles
negociaciones de paz y os preguntaréis
qué hace la india al respecto pues
exacto mejorar continuamente su arsenal
nuclear y qué haces cuando tu vecino te
puede atacar los hilos nucleares pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
guerra nuclear os imagináis que dentro
de 20 años el presidente de españa sea
andrés iniesta bueno pues en pakistán el
primer ministro es el hombre que llegó a
su país a la victoria en el mundial de
cricket imran khan al igual que sus
predecesores
imran khan intentó mejorar las
relaciones con la india y justo en ese
momento los terroristas de james y
mohamed organizaron la peor masacre de
cachemira en los últimos 30 años y ahí
es cuando el primer ministro indio
narendra modi dijo
pakistán mira en un momento te voy a
decir una cosa aquí en la india estamos
rezando una ristra de hojas así de
grande y tiene todas las papeletas que
te parece pakistán
[Música]
en otras palabras que por primera vez en
décadas
india bombardeo territorio paquistaní
es decir no atacó cachemira que es lo
habitual en estos casos sino
directamente pakistán pero atentos
porque aquí viene lo realmente
importante en estos momentos la india ha
hecho un movimiento crucial en este
duelo mexicano del que hablábamos antes
y ese movimiento tiene un nombre y ns
and giran el destructor de enemigos
[Música]
el submarino nuclear y en s
completa su patrulla la tríada nuclear
del país en operación recordáis que os
decíamos que pakistán podía usar sus
armas estratégicas para destruir los
silos nucleares de la india pues bien
los indios son conscientes de esto y por
eso han comprado submarinos nucleares la
ventaja de un submarino nuclear es que
tu arsenal atómico ya no está en un
punto fijo sino que lo puedes tener
moviéndose continuamente bajo el agua es
decir que es casi imposible encontrarlo
y destruirlo y eso explica que el
ejército pakistaní se pusiera tan
nervioso y aquí es cuando casi todos los
medios de comunicación empezaron a
hablar de una posible guerra nuclear
pero de verdad posible una guerra
nuclear la verdad es que no lo parece
para empezar aunque la india atacara
territorio pakistaní se limitaron a
bombardear campos de entrenamiento de
terroristas es decir que no llegaron a
cruzar las líneas rojas de lo que
pakistán considera una invasión así que
cuál fue la respuesta de pakistán al
bombardeo pues una pequeña escaramuza
aérea en la india pero seamos honestos
los últimos que quieren una guerra
nuclear son pakistán y si no mirad lo
que dice uno de sus anteriores
presidentes
[Música]
si atacamos con un arma nuclear india
podría terminar con nosotros con 20
pervez musharraf todo esto explica
porque pakistán no tardó ni tres días en
devolver al piloto indio que fue
capturado en su territorio es más es que
si pakistán tuviera la más mínima
tentación de volver a atacar india ha
dejado las cosas muy pero que muy
claritas
india despliega submarinos nucleares y
un portaaviones en el mar arábigo para
disuadir aventuras de pakistán vamos que
de nuevo ninguno de estos dos países
está realmente dispuesto a un
enfrentamiento nuclear real entonces
quien sale ganando de todo esto es nada
más y nada menos que el primer ministro
indio narendra modi
[Música]
porque si mis queridos amigos de visual
política la india acaba de celebrar
elecciones presidenciales y narendra
modi ha vuelto a arrasar pero de eso
vamos a hablar en un próximo vídeo
porque como os podéis imaginar cómo no
íbamos a cubrir las elecciones indias en
visual político
faltaría más es que parece que no nos
conocéis y por supuesto si no os queréis
perder ese vídeo ya estáis tardando en
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y mientras
tanto la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que india y pakistán pueden
llevarse bien algún día podría
recrudecerse el conflicto después de las
elecciones podeis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y si
quieres aprender más de política sin
prejuicios ideológicas y a la vez
seguiré escuchando mi preciosa voz no te
pierdas el podcast the vikings share
donde hablamos de política sin pensar
por ti visita big estero y miriam
puntocom
las vacas nos vemos allí si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]